[Music]
so I'm interested in Duet AI but
particularly duet AI in app sheet like
how can I automate with just those tools
that's right so recall that duet AI
which may who's heard the term duet AI a
time or two at next so far a few of us
have it's our new generative AI
capability it's integrated into the core
of both Google workspace and Google
Cloud right and it can help you write
code analyze security threats and even
develop
let's take kind of a gnarly use case and
let's see how far we can get into it
using just duet a and app sheet before
we have to parachute out into some kind
of custom code I wanted to easily
capture data using a phone or tablet so
anyone in the school or on the shop
floor can initiate a report the safety
team should have an operational
dashboard so they can track and escalate
issues and we're going to want some help
from it to establish a method for AI to
evaluate the pictures for specific areas
to see if they are in compliance sounds
good so let me see if I can get that
into a prompt that du I can use so I
need to capture incident reports each
incident has a type status description a
date and each incident should be
assigned to what a team member right so
let's put this in and see what happens
now I didn't exactly give duet AI an
architecture diagram there so it's going
to be interesting to see how it things
an app like this should be built and
look at this what it gave us is a couple
of tables so we've got a team memb table
and we've got an incidence table and as
we can see by this team member ID it
seems to think there should be some
relationship between them so that seems
cool we can click on this little pencil
if we want to make changes to this but
actually I think we can also do that
through chat can I just narrate it with
my voice that is a great use for another
cool thing we just Shi which is
unstructured audio capture with duet AI
so try this I want you to hit that plus
button there all right and then hit the
audio button and we're going to see if
we can just narrate this new incident
report you don't have to like narrate
exactly what's in each field which is
good cuz you can't actually see them
right now just kind of tell duet more or
less what you think should be in this
report and we'll see if it can connect
the dots I mean as a developer with
existing workloads you're likely going
to have existing apis and LL models and
and so on that you want to make
available to other parts of the business
and it turns out that app sheet lets you
put a new front end on that stuff super
quickly while staying in the Google
workspace world of single sign on with
familiar forms and such exactly so let's
say that I've built an amazing vers Tex
AI Vision model to help identify
pictures of workstations that are out of
compliance actually let's not say that
let's show it I actually have that app
available right now it's built out in a
different Google Cloud project um it's
behind an apog API and it looks a little
something like this okay cool so you can
see some amazing uh developer styling
going on in that diagram but uh what
we're looking at here is it's a a cloud
run service that uh fronts vertex AI
it's going to run a few little uh
prompts for us and then it's going to
come back asynchronously and call back
to app sheet everyone say app sheet app
sheet awesome all right okay save let's
hit Y let's hit save all right and now
if you pop open this card here okay it's
going to take a second for vertex AI to
read this
picture let's see if du AI in Cloud
workstations can uh help us write some
code excellent I'm a big fan of duet AI
doing autoc completion of code but also
it can generate entire blocks of code
here for example you have a comment just
from that we and generate all the code
we need to talk to postgress database to
Loop through the rows and then to email
each customer that has an abandoned card
look my parents raised me right so I'm
also going to add some test coverage to
this and so right from the IDE I can
pick the operation or even do it right
from chat but I could pick the operation
and say generate unit tests it'll jump
over to the DU AI chat right where we
can ask questions but'll also throw me
some unit tests which I can copy back
into my code run them and make good
choices here
AI generated summary is actually
generated by du AI that's right yeah you
may remember this from the main keynote
yesterday but it's going to give us some
verbiage about how we why it's not good
that we have an admin service account
with all these extra privileges but
watch this we can actually go deeper
than just a summary if I click on the
attack score itself these attack
exposure scores you'll see next to these
vulnerabilities now and that's just
based on WE rank these vulnerabilities
as high medium or low concern we have a
numeric score assigned to those you can
actually configure that if you want uh
but you know a high is bad low score is
good it's like golf uh and if I click on
this number 21 here and select the
organization uh you should see something
super cool which is our attack path
simulation so let me zoom in on that so
you can see it a little bit better what
do you think about that we are killing
this man anyway look at what jet is
doing here right it picked up a number
of things for us uh we've got a secure
service account key that's available
from the public internet I like these
little red uh exclamation points here
because it actually points to if we have
other um related vulnerabilities there's
kind of this fractally integrated set of
problems in our account we can kind of
explore that in any dire it's like
Choose Your Own Adventure it's all
mapped out for us here in this nice
little attack path simulation and it
brings us all the way down to our demo
bucket which is where we have our build
log stored so all that build metadata we
were creating before is actually
potentially exposed right now and this
is a good note that we need to fix it so
uh yes that's uh that's where we're at I
I'll be honest I feel like my mind just
melted a little bit here one of my
longstanding forward wishing look
looking uh just goals for cloud overall
just say hey AI just tell me which of
these containers have vulnerabilities
which policies are over permission and
just give me the steps to remediate them
don't make me guess don't make me put
together a bunch of tools and it really
feels like we're starting to get there
let's see if you can get it to find like
a specific type of safety incident like
maybe all the reports that say injury or
something right CU I'm terrible at
writing sequel so when I can just give
it a comment and have it give me a query
statement that's uh that's make it
everybody better it'll also give me some
options I might look and say that's not
the one I want or hey that looks close
all right let's pick that one run that
and what it should give me then I'm
querying that I'm getting only two
records back because we have in injury
somewhere in that audio transcription
which is awesome so when you're ready to
take off your analyst hat and put on
your ml engineer hat what hat is that uh
we can switch over to vertex
AI okay look at this this is the same
notebook so this is the same notebook
we're looking at can you call
Palm can you extend that with vertex NE
do summarization from there yeah so
let's let's actually invoke the Palm API
so we can summarize maybe that lengthy
summary there and get back a nice little
description that we can figure out which
factories are a hot
mess oh there we go I think you showed
me the little magic wand button before
look at that I like the wand you know it
doesn't take a lot to please me there we
go and so if we come back we see there's
a summary I'm getting a single sentence
summary of what might be a really long
transcription and I'm doing all this in
the data frame again I'm not leaving my
tool set
[Music]
w